Oh Jimmy Fallon sometimes we love your
interviews and sometimes well not so
much
we know you're a funny guy and your time
on SNL was legendary but sometimes
things on your show get a little weird
while we love Jimmy Fallon's hilarious
games and his backup band the roots
you've got to admit he's not always the
smoothest interviewer even with the best
celebrities on his show sometimes things
just get plain awkward today we're
taking a look at some of the cringe
iasts to take place on The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon look cardi B is a
whole lot of energy if this woman comes
on your show you've got to know how to
play along because she is at a hundred
percent every day of her life and she's
hilarious
she'll never shy away from showing the
world exactly who she is and we love her
for that but when she went on Jimmy
Fallon in 2017 it seemed pretty clear
that Jimmy had no idea how to talk to
her but I it was right after boudic
yellow burst onto the music scene and
cardi took the world by storm she
appeared on Fallon's show in a bright
green top with giant fur sleeves and as
soon as she started uh Turing her now
trademark sounds Jimmy completely lost
his train of thought instead of playing
along or just laughing along with her he
instead took super long awkward very
tense pauses in which he leaves car D
completely hanging and his audience has
no choice but to chuckle awkwardly to
fill the silence Oh Jimmy hardy deserved
better
hey this cardi B and you watching are
Ward's video vaults okay
so Jimmy Fallon laughing is just now a
part of his whole thing we know he's
gonna giggle through just about
everything even if it completely derails
the interview that fact is the most
obvious in a 2016 interview with Nicole
Kidman
as soon as Nicole sits down Jimmy is
already wheezing with laughter clearly
feeling incredibly awkward about the
whole thing see back in 2015 on his show
Nicole revealed that she once had a
crush on the then SNL star and that the
two of them had a very dicey non
date date arranged by a mutual friend
during the date
Fallon thought she was coming over for a
meeting even though she thought very
differently she claims that he barely
spoke to her and then started playing a
video game halfway through so when she
came back on his show in 2016 the two
were both clearly still feeling weird
about the whole thing they can barely
let the other finish a sentence and have
a hard time making it through the
interview at all but is that the last
time that we saw
you're kidding are you part of the late
night hosts job is to playfully make fun
of their guests the key word here being
playfully but when Blake Shelton came on
the show in 2017 he had a bone to pick
with Jimmy who had spent the entire
beginning of his show making fun of the
country singers album cover as soon as
he sits down Shelton immediately calls
out Fallon for roasting him the
15-minute segment you did try to help me
sell records for once instead of
addressing it and getting on with the
interview Jimmy continues poking fun at
Shelton's photo on the album cover even
when the singer clearly indicates that
he's over the bit when Jimmy starts
imitating his accent it's pretty obvious
that Shelton is just barely keeping his
cool and that his smile is plastered on
in order to cover up his real annoyance
even the audience seems to be laughing
in order to fill the silence in between
jobs while Shelton might be overreacting
to some pretty gentle jokes it's still
up to the host to read the room and know
when to stop which Jimmy just can't seem
to do sometimes it takes a colleague to
really call you out on what you're doing
and that's exactly what John Oliver did
when he appeared on the show in 2018 all
of our hosts the HBO show last week
tonight with John Oliver and came on
Fallon in order to promote his turn as
Zazu in The Lion King and yet the entire
interview turns into a big call out of
what Oliver refers to as Hollywood BS
especially when Jimmy decides to give
Oliver a very weird half compliment when
talking about his late-night show Jimmy
tells John Oliver that his show has the
best title of any show ever
Oliver immediately calls him out for
damning him with faint praise
that the best title while that sounds
like damning me with faint praise Jimmy
thank you yeah which is kind of true you
know when you go see a friend's weird
experimental theater show and then they
come up to you afterwards so you
desperately try to think of something to
say and you wind up saying something
like Wow
the lighting was amazing that's pretty
much the equivalent of what Fallon did
to Oliver and he called him out for it
right away before it makes no sense an
SNL star Pete Davidson is known for
being off-the-cuff so it's not really
surprising that his first appearance on
Jimmy Fallon almost seemed like it could
be his last in 2018 when Davidson was
still engaged to Ariana Grande he
stopped by the show to chat with Jimmy
about it it all started off fine but
when Fallon suggested that the two stars
get married on his show Davidson switch
topics and changed the mood entirely he
asked why anyone would care and it's Ted
brought up the controversy between
Donald Trump and stormy Daniels the
audience clearly didn't know quite what
to do with that one and mostly went
quiet
Davidson saved it with a cheeky thumbs
up to the camera and then they switch to
talking about how awesome the other
guest Robert Pattinson was instead I
think he's one of the greatest actors of
our generation the awkwardness did not
end there though as the conversation
turned back to Davidson's ariana grande
tattoo Davidson used some pretty
colorful language to express his shock
that what he does ends up in the news
and when Jimmy reminded him that he
can't swear on network TV Davidson jokes
that he'll just go to Seth Meyers show
instead can't say that word on
television you asked me to be on here it
must be a dream of any comedian to get
to share a room with both Steve Martin
and Martin Short but that dream quickly
turned into a bit of a nightmare when
the two legends sat down on Jimmy
Fallon's couch and immediately said
about roasting him hard you proved the
tall handsome white men can make it in
show business
while they do it very playfully there
are some real jabs in there Martin Short
goes so far as to tell Fallon that no
late night host pretends to care the way
he does the two comedy heroes barely let
Jimmy get a question in and instead just
do 10 minutes of improv making fun of
each other and Jimmy himself they crack
jokes about how on
funny his monologue is make a ton of
political jokes and make up stories
about just about anything except for the
show that they came on to plug it might
not be the most productive interview or
even an interview at all but it's no
less entertaining Canadian heartthrob
Shawn Mendes has graced the Jimmy Fallon
show not once but twice and both have
been pretty awkward the first time in
2016 saw Shawn sitting in with the band
for Jimmy's bit called hashtag fall
songs in which Mendes sang tweets about
fall to the tune of famous songs the
first one went okay but when Jimmy gave
him the wrong cue for the second song
Mendes wasn't afraid to call him out
about it he then made a joke about Jimmy
being old instead of playing along
Fallon seemed to get confused by the
remark and left Mendes hanging in the
awkwardness trying to cover up his first
quip by claiming that Jimmy isn't old
Shawn is just very young which you know
is true the whole thing got off to a
very strange start but the young pop
star quickly recovered by nailing all of
the other songs
Joaquin Phoenix has never been the
easiest guy to interview just ask David
Letterman what well can you tell us
about your days with the Unabomber the
notoriously shy actor only does press
when he absolutely has to and is clearly
very uncomfortable about it so when he
came on Jimmy Fallon's show to promote
Joker things got awkward just as you
might expect them to Fallon starts
trying to play a game with Joaquin in
which he has a bunch of facts on a card
that may or may not be true and the
point is for the audience to guess which
is true and which is not we think but
the thing is he never explains exactly
what Joaquin is supposed to do and they
spend most of their time just trying to
clarify what the rules are
we'll give this one to Jimmy Fallon it
must be really hard to talk to Ricky
Gervais not only is he incredibly quick
he's intensely opinionated and will
barrel right through any conversation
without letting you get a word in
edgewise
as soon as Gervais sits down on Fallon
Jimmy tells him that he looks great
Gervais jumps right in to shut that
compliment down accusing the host of
being sarcastic
before monologuing for the next four and
a half minutes straight I look great
yeah is that sarcasm no Jimmy has no
choice but to just watch and laugh
forgoing any chance at getting a
question in and instead of giving in
Fallon keeps looking to his producers
and down at his desk shaking his head in
disbelief at one point he even crumples
up his notes indicating that there's no
point in even trying but it all gets a
little too real when Gervase lays into
obese children and then drops an f-bomb
Fallon stops laughing altogether and
looks off-camera clearly being told to
wrap it up fast a beast was the polite
word that was the polite word so we
didn't have to say [ __ ] the most
infamous Jimmy Fallon misstep has got to
be his interview with Donald Trump while
he was still only in the running for
president of the United States Jimmy
Fallon took it upon himself to invite
The Apprentice star on his show and it
went well not great early on when Jimmy
jokingly asks Trump if he still wants to
do this an audience member can be heard
shouting don't do it before Trump can
answer you you still have time do you
still want to do this I think this time
I then came the moment that caused a
huge media storm in a move that he has
since gone on to regret Jimmy playfully
ruffled Trump's hair at the very end of
the interview as the audience went wild
so did the media and the moment would go
down in history who some of those were
just painful what did you think of this
video what was your favorite
cringe-worthy moment is there a good one
that we missed let us know down in the
comments and don't forget to hit that
subscribe button to keep up with all of
the latest videos from the things
[Music]